here with more is president Trump's
attorney he has done work for me also in
the past but he got a bigger client now
good for him also the chief counsel
American Center for Law and Justice Jay
Sekulow hey Jon the president's right
Jay they the the left in this country
and the media have declared war on this
president but more importantly it really
is also against the smelly Walmart
people like me and irredeemable
deplorable Zand people that cling to God
guns Bibles and religion because they
don't like who we elected and they want
to undo an election in all of this well
look I mean here's what happened the the
Russia hoax ends up being nothing when
Bob Mahler did that attempted testimony
whatever that was that got him zero
the report was nothing the testimony was
nothing then they come up with the
Ukraine now I want to read something in
this so-called whistleblower I call spy
I don't know the person obviously by the
way but when you read what the
individual wrote it sounds like spying
but the one thing that is written I was
not a direct witness to most of the
events described so this is hearsay in
our view by the way if the witness
actually said that in a court of law
in the Middle District of Georgia saying
Macon they won't be admitted into court
it's called hearsay now here's an
interesting fact it's just coming to
light right now this person says they
have no first-hand knowledge of this
they heard this from other people the
forum that so-called whistleblowers
fill-out used to say this in order to
find an urgent concern credible the
Inspector General must be in possession
of reliable first-hand information in
other words the Inspector General and
the individual making the complaint so
that would be the first-hand information
has to have first-hand information that
was on the form literally until
apparently very recently none of the
exact date of the change but it looks
like it could have been changed as late
as July or August I don't have the exact
date yet but I will tell you this months
ago no first-hand information no report
so what is this this is hearsay secondly
what
they here say what the American people
should be thinking about right now is
we've got individuals inside of some
agency that are listening to the
president's conversations they don't
like them so they want them out so the
White House is being fully transparent
released these transcripts now let me
tell you something the transparencies
great but if you think this is good for
America that we're going through this
guess again
foreign leaders will be hesitant that's
my concern it's always been my concern
here Farley doesn't be hesitant in
engaging in phone conversations with
this kind of nonsense going on now let
me take it a step further Nancy Pelosi
announces that she's going to start this
formal impeachment inquiry which by the
way substantively was no difference but
than what they've been doing for the
last year or three they did not refer
this to the floor of the house for a
vote wine articles ought to be referred
to a committee for the Judiciary
Committee pranic was impeachment she did
that before she even read this report so
what do you have here this is not a
legal matter I want people to understand
this I know my friend and colleague Rudy
Giuliani is gonna be on this isn't a
legal manner this is pure politics and
whatever the political calculation is
which i think is a very desperate move
if they were to march down this path
I think it's political suicide for those
that would do that because what a sign
of desperation does anybody really
believe that that 14 seconds uh turd in
that statement in the in the
conversation if you put all the
references to Joe Biden and the hundred
vine which is - and the and the in that
entire situation together and you put in
my colleague reference to Rudy Giuliani
that was raised by the way by the
president of Ukraine who first raised it
I think it may equal 20 seconds 30
seconds and a conversation that was the
transportation 30 minutes I'm sure the
translation is probably you know a third
or less than that but it's probably at
least you know 15 to 20 minutes and
that's going to be the articles of
impeachment go ahead start the process
boat because this is bordering not only
on the absurd but I think there is a
dereliction of constitutional duties if
you ignore the Constitution itself
there's no high crime
no misdemeanor no violation of a law
rule or regulation it's already been at
the Justice Department when they looked
at it said there was no violation here
so I think this is just a political
theater that's what it is
Jay Sekulow thank you